it was a mission like no other
thousands of afghans escaped their
country crammed into the back of
military planes
terrified tired and at times travel sick
for the air crew it was a humbling and
harrowing experience
the conditions were stark you know when
you look down the back you've got
anxious faces uh you had some people who
didn't think they were going to leave
afghanistan so when they got on board
the airplane the you know the the relief
led to you know some spontaneous
reactions like you know we have one lady
who is spontaneously vomiting
continuously all over the airplane
because she'd lost her husband the day
before and she didn't know what was
going to happen
c-17s like this one were able to cram in
more than 400 people at a time strapped
to the floor many of them children
they kept flying even after a suicide
bomb attack outside kabul airport left
dozens dead
in the chaos that followed this pilot
narrowly avoided an even deadlier
disaster when a bus carrying evacuees
turned into his path on the runway as he
was trying to take off
we were about 95 knots
and they were about a thousand feet
ahead of us and we realized that we
wouldn't have been able to reject the
takeoff um because if i tried to reject
then i would have basically cleaned up
the bus and taken out the bus and
that doesn't really bear thinking about
so i had to continue the takeoff we got
airborne and we just missed the bus by
probably about 10 15 feet it's one of
many tales of courage starting to emerge
from the two-week evacuation mission
the royal air force's transport fleet
played a vital role in flying families
to safety
one of its aircraft tried to land on the
day after kabul fell to the taliban
the pilot saw the airfield overrun with
frantic afghans clinging to planes on
the ground
we couldn't see the runway till about
two miles out um and it it all looked
clear and then at about a hundred feet
um a civilian vehicle drove across the
runway hotly pursued by three military
vehicles so we had to necessitate a go
around and on the go around we could see
the airfield was completely overrun
there was people on the
taxiways people on the southern apron
the civilian airliners that were already
parked there were completely covered in
people with them on the wings clambering
all over the top of them it was just
utter chaos and did you see that
american plane that was trying to take
off that was on the ground when we were
there um we obviously didn't make it
down on the ground
another pilot revealed how the airport
had come under mortar fire a day earlier
the u.s marines in the tower called
incoming and base under attack um we had
had some rounds impacting the ground
around our aircraft while we howard
shore to the runway
uh and i recall an american helicopter
pilot calling mortars inbound and he
flew off to have a look at the mortar
tube
no british aircraft were damaged during
the evacuation mission and everyone
returned safely proud to have played
their part
albeit a role in britain's afghan
retreat
debra haynes sky news